deux radios nous sommes debout de très
bonne heure la voie existante et
chevrotante et les cours tant pour des
millions de canadiens durant la seconde
guerre mondiale aux liens précieux une
source d'information inestimable
le matin du 6 juin 1944
marcel wimet reporter de guerre de radio
canada est un témoin privilégié du
débarquement de normandie
une fumée grise et noire remet au centre
du village et quelques temps quand on
sait qu'au moment où ils connaissent au
taf et répétés sur la plage layec
l'attaqué commencé et elle coud marcel
wimet est aux premières loges
il suit les soldats du régiment
chaudière qui débarque à bernières sur
mer
l'heure h lorsque l'on sait c'est qu'il
arrive entre 9h30 10h du matin dans la
deuxième vague d'assaut il débarque avec
une mare est déjà bien avancé l'eau
jusqu'à la ceinture
il saute de la barge d'assaut il prend
sa machine à écrire sur l'épaule et à
bout de bras pour ne pas clos évidemment
aux dommages sa machine à écrire et il
avance d'avant ce journaliste et
historien c'est un peu par hasard que
jean baptiste patier a découvert ces
reportages anciens inconnu des français
est tombé dans l'oubli
au canada les reportages de marcel mi
mai sont exceptionnelles parce qu'ils
sont vraiment très précis d'un point de
vue historique et s'intéressent beaucoup
aussi aux populations civiles
on sait que j'ai eus enfants se sont
juste derrière des normands convaincus
par quelques parisiens aussi qu'il est
venu à la plage plus d'accord c'était un
autre genre de nerfs 75 ans plus tard
paul lise et renée ouimet faute à leur
tour le sable de bernières sur mer
c'est la première fois que les trois
filles de marcel wimet bien ensemble en
normandie
je passe sur la plage qui ont tous deux
un pèlerinage
ça c'est très tranquille et paisible
c'était pas comme ça le jour j
aujourd'hui départ commun ils disent les
haines les quelques jours quand sow et
muta parce qu'elle est sa machine à
écrire sur sa marque un tournant majeur
de la seconde guerre mondiale le début
de la fin pour l'allemagne nazie mais ça
marcel wimet tu ne le fais pas encore
lorsqu ils s'embarquent aux côtés des
soldats canadiens à destination de la
france
en fait il ne sait même pas s'il va en
sortir vivant
les trois soeurs oui mais elles ont
connu un peu l'envers du décor les
coulisses de cette couverture de guerre
telle que racontée par leur père est
relatée dans ces lettres qui écrivait
chaque jour marcel wimet à sa femme
jacqueline certaines comme celle ci
écrite d'un navire la veille du
débarquement sont empreintes d'une forte
émotion prix pour moi et fait aussi
prier notre fille est les prières de ces
petits anges ne manque jamais être
exaucé je confie toute mon affection
toute ma tendresse et tout mon amour à
cette missive soit sûr qu'aujourd'hui
que demain et les jours qui suivront
je ne cesserai pas beaucoup de penser à
toi moi j'ai senti la part entre quant à
placer l'être la part puis
comme tellement d'autres l'attend pas
savoir ce qui va arriver
muni de son micro de ses jumelles de son
appareil photo et de sa machine à écrire
marcel wimet témoigne jour après jour
des batailles les plus brutales comme
celle de l'aérodrome de carpiquet ai
jamais vu une bataille épique bernanke
matin mais voyons avancer en même temps
nous à chaque jour ils continuent de
confier ses états d'âme à son épouse
dans des missives plus candide les unes
que les autres
on découvre aussi les analyses d'un
homme à dire qu'il ne peut pas donner
son opinion dans un reportage qui est
donc voué à tous les auditeurs de radio
canada
donc il va donner son opinion sur
l'opinion par exemple sur les
bombardements alliés alors que dans ses
reportages
il va parler de précision mathématique
dans ses lettres il à dire mais c'est
terrible ce que nous avons fait nous les
a niés dans ces villes normandes ravagé
par les bombardements
ces lettres les soeurs oui mais les ont
remises à l'historien jean baptiste
papier qui a décidé d'en faire un livre
le destin de marcel humez est
exceptionnel parce qu'il a tout connu du
6 juin 1944 des plages de normandie en
passant par le discours de de gaulle à
chartres par le discours de de gaulle à
bayeux à paris sur les champs elysées le
26 août 1944
marcel wimet ne peut retenir son émotion
à l'antenne lorsqu'ils entrent dans
paris libéré et si marcel wimet de
radio-canada qui vous parle de paris oui
le pari enfin les livrer complètement
libéré nous avons tellement passé depuis
hier après-midi par toute la gamme des
émotions
l'accueil des populations parisienne a
été tellement fantastique
la joie du peuple une véritable
explosion la libération de paris
le fait d'avoir suivi ce général de
gaulle en rentrant tall sall a beaucoup
ému
parce que il était était très h est
attaché à la france
c'est à ce destin exceptionnel un peu
oublié qui a voulu rendre hommage à
jean-baptiste pâti dans son livre marcel
wimet un reporter au coeur de la
libération lui avec son humilité et bien
une mérite je pense que l'on redonne
toute sa place dans l'histoire
à marseille mais l'histoire du
journalisme de guerre et l'histoire de
la seconde guerre mondiale moi en tout
cas j'espère que cela va permettre aux
canadiens de savoir ce que mon père pour
moi ça représente d'honorer papa et puis
le faire connaître
finalement pour qu'ils étaient comme
correspondant de guerre on croyait qu'un
journaliste incroyable un écrivain
incroyable
l'écrivain courir en lice pour tous et
surtout été un témoin de son temps
la prime est ici jean françois bélanger
radio canada qui vous parle de france